il y en a pas deux comme toi d'un moment
c'est pas une idiote sacré caractère que
tu vas changer un jour tout le monde
connaîtra ton nom j'ai une spla
alors tu veux devenir chanteur oh non
monsieur
j'aimerais plutôt faire mécanicien
d'un problème
tu fais de la musique ça m'empêche de
devenir dingue ici
c'est une vraie bête de scène il a été
touché par la grâce ces rires peut-être
qu'on pourrait faire des gammes toi et
moi on savait tous ces gens james
quand est-ce qu'on montera sur scène
maintenant quoi passer outre
[Musique]
et un souci je sais on peut pas jouer
comme tu veux ça que le voir la musique
est-ce que ça sonne bien est ce que ça
donne bien ouais
si ça sonne bien que ça donne dias et
musicale et un gîte dans une partie des
règles sont déjà fixés je veux qu'un
gosse des rues d'augusta aujourd'hui
regarde je dis moi ce que tu vois ce
président je veux à l'aube et pour qu'on
apporte du grand méchant funk arnaud
gaillard explique un harnais mais c'est
d'être joué quelques fois on aujourd'hui
je veux entrer dans l'histoire comme le
mec qui a tué le funk il ya une femme
qui dit être ta maman bébé passe à
l'apollo je suis pas ton bébé ni à
l'époque ni aujourd'hui je prends soin
de james mois personne ni personne
quand je vais mettre le feu sur scène va
falloir vous accrocher surtout vous les
petits blancs tous les noirs dans cet
immeuble marcher la tête haute avec cap
soir
affaire classée monsieur peur j'ai bien
peur que non monsieur brown
j'ai dit à faire classer je dis qu'on a
encore du funk en stock
ouvrez grand vos oreilles
ce type est un génie
nom de dieu
[Musique]